i don't know whether to be excited or
scared hey what's up guys my name is
zacchano
and welcome to vulcan week i'm gonna try
and keep this as short as possible
because it's supposed to start in like
25 minutes and i have to quickly
chuck this video up but basically what
vulcan week is is me
live streaming this entire week monday
to friday
10 a.m australian eastern standard time
to 6 p.m every single day this week
i will be live streaming on twitch.tv
slash the channel and i will be
implementing like or adding vulcan
support
to hazeldev's renderer so for those of
you who don't know hazel dev currently
and hazel itself as well the game engine
series
they both use opengl at the moment and
for numerous reasons i've wanted to
actually
add vulcan support for quite a while and
i thought that the best
the best way to deal with this is just
to probably just sit down and just work
at it all week don't get distracted with
anything else just sit down and just
work really hard and just do it all in
one week and that is what is happening
this week now i want to make a few notes
here first of all why are we adding
vulcan support
i mentioned recently that i wanted to go
back and polish a lot of what hazel
has to offer the previous halo devlog
which i'll link up there actually talks
a lot about you know how good is good
enough and do we want to go back and
kind of you know make
things better and i decided that yes i
did want to go back and make things
better this is part of that kind of
polishing pass i want it's really
important for me to get vulcan down
and like for hazel to start supporting
that for
quite a lot of reasons to be honest
primarily because it's going to lay
the groundwork the foundation for the
rest of
hazel's renderer opengl is not a very
uh how should we say this normal
rendering api there are a lot of
concepts in there that are missing or
that we have to emulate when we deal
with other apis
such as directx or even even dirt x11
not to mention directx 12
and vulcan as well and getting some of
those concepts down structuring our
renderer around
vulcan instead of around opengl is going
to
actually lay a lot of groundwork for us
to be able to later implement directx a
lot more easily or metal
if we choose to go down that route as
well but the other big difference is
that vulcan obviously supports
a lot more things than opengl does
namely ray tracing one of my goals
this year is to actually add ray tracing
to hazel i want to be able to do
something ray trace whether that be like
ray trace reflections or shadows or
you know global elimination something
like that i want to have some form of
ray tracing
in hazeldev by the end of the year and
obviously to make that happen i'm going
to need to use either vulcan or directx
12.
welcome being the much more kind of
flexible api it supports more platforms
i can run it on windows mac although
that's
we'll see what happens with that linux
and android as well which means it's a
lot more flexible to me as a solo
developer to use rather than directx 12
which of course is windows and xbox only
so anyway because of all of those
reasons i think it's really good to add
vulcan support to hazel because it's
just going to lay the foundation for
very very exciting things to come in the
future as well as force me to actually
write
like a better renderer because it's the
way that vulcan is structured for those
of you who have used it it kind of
forces you to do that because it's a lot
more low level and you have to think a
lot more about what the gpu is actually
doing and what you want it to do
and where and how and all that stuff now
let's talk about
my experience with falcon in the past i
have been
i've been using vulcan since probably
before it
officially came out back when i worked
at ea we added it to our mobile engine
which also supported windows
and uh that was uh you know a fun
experience i didn't play too big of a
role in that part but i was exposed to a
lot of falcon codes a lot of testing all
of that stuff so that was my first
experience with vulcan
back then it was very uh
very dodgy it um you know frequently we
tried to get it to run on android and if
it crashed it just rebooted the android
device there were a lot of driver issues
and that was my first kind of
you know being like whoa that's this
vulcan thing needs this [ __ ] thing
needs some work to make it good
and since then i mean i know it's
improved a lot i haven't used it
too much since then i think the only
thing i've really done
is about nine or ten months ago i
basically took
the game engine series version of hazel
which just has like a 2d renderer
and i added vulcan support to that that
was
10 months ago and whilst that did work
and i did learn a lot more about vulcan
during that period of time i haven't
touched vulcan code
in about nine or ten months and what
that means
at least for me is i've basically
forgotten everything
like i i mean i have you know i know
what render passes ready command buffers
you know all of those
kind of pipelines i remember what how
that stuff loosely works
but i it's not like opengl where i could
probably sit down and just
you know write an opengl program or a
renderer that works on paper because i
just know all of the api so well
vulcan is not like that at all and to be
honest it's a lot more of a burst so i
don't think remembering something like
that is something that a lot of people
are able to actually do
uh so it's gonna be fun i think it's
gonna be very challenging
this week i don't know how much i'm
gonna get done this week i'm gonna give
it my best shot
there is a lot of stuff that has to be
done in hazeldev first before we can
even start vulcan
so i think last live stream that i did
which was on friday i started
uh basically rewriting the whole shader
compiler and the whole shader system
inside hazel
to use spur v which is like a binary
shader format instead of
basically what i was doing which was
just using the opengl compiler and then
actually
uh using like a parser that i wrote to
go through all the uniforms and figure
out their types and you know
create uniform buffers basically well we
didn't actually use uniform buffers but
like makeshift
client-side uniform buffers and all of
that stuff it was quite an interesting
little system that i've basically
started rewriting so that it all uses
spur-v spurvi's reflection
um but we can also compile stuff
actually online like at runtime and
it's it's pretty cool but there's that
needs to be done before we can even
start vulcan
so today's livestream is going to be
probably focused
on getting spurvi to actually work with
opengl first and then we're going to
start on vulcan so there's
a few a few like housekeeping things
that need to be done before we can like
dive in and actually start working on
the vulcan renderer
hopefully that's not going to take more
than just today to figure out and then
the rest of the week can be devoted to
vulcan
there's also a lot of planning i think
that needs to be done in order to
get this stuff off the ground anyway the
point is it's
a lot of hard work but i'm really
looking forward to it we'll see how we
go
twitch or tv for slash the channel the
live stream starts in like 20 minutes
according to this if i can get this
video out in time
so uh definitely check out the schedule
as well twitter tv
slash the channel schedule because that
will uh
you know in your time zone that'll show
you what hours i'm actually
streaming in so if you're interested in
catching any of those streams then
you can check that out now as for like
the video recordings of streams the vods
they're going to be available to twitch
subscribers and to patrons as well as
usual so patreon.com you'll get the vods
indefinitely
because on twitch they actually expire
after 14 days so if you're interested in
or if you're not catching the streams or
you want to watch them later as well
then you can uh help support me and get
access to all those
vods as well it's a win-win anyway i'm
really excited for this to be honest and
a little bit scared
as i mentioned it's not just going to be
about me implementing vulkan it's
also going to be about me learning
vulcan again because i feel i feel like
i've learnt it at least three times in
my life and i keep forgetting it because
if you don't keep using vulcan i feel
like it's just so complicated that
you'll just slowly forget
everything and then you'll have to start
again so it's going to be a lot of fun
uh
lots of uh lots of tears to be had i
think
but um hope to see you guys there and i
will see you next time one more thing i
wanted to add as well was that obviously
because of this there's not gonna be any
videos this week i think
no there's going to be one on friday i
believe but apart from that like normal
videos are not really going to be
happening this week instead we're doing
this baltimore
thing so yeah anyway see you guys there
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
you